hi everyone today I'm here with Jess who
runs her own YouTube channels demonym
yes it's a YouTube channel about doing
you know science science education
videos and Technology vlogs with a focus
on engineering and technology and
conservation yes and so jess is an
engineer that's what you've studied and
well with my background in maths and
physics what we're going to talk about
today is talking through some tools that
we've used
you know tools for stem majors we're
gonna work through a list of things that
we've found helpful and the idea is to
just raise awareness of these things for
you if you've never been exposed to them
before for example the first thing that
we're going to talk about is something
called Wolfram Alpha and this is
something where you can essentially do
maths or solve tricky integrals and when
I was at high school I had no idea that
this software existed and when I got to
uni I was actually quite far into uni
maybe quite fast through first yeah a
little too late before I saw someone or
thesan oh let's just check this integral
on Wolfram Alpha and I was like check
this integral like what you can do that
so yeah I guess I'd like to tell you
guys about this so that you don't find
yourself in that same situation so yeah
that that first one was Wolfram Alpha
and back when I was a student Wolfram
was it would show you so you would put
in your integral or your derivative or
you can also solve matrices and do
linear algebra and Wolfram Alpha which
is really cool and you would put it in
and it would actually give you a
step-by-step solution so you can see
every single step along the way and now
they've changed it right so now you can
just see the answer yes I think if when
you go to the main website like Wolfram
Alpha calm or whatever it is and you
type in an equation it
you you want the souls me just shows you
the answer and it wants you to pay like
I think it's maybe like seven dollars a
month or something for the pro version
to see these step-by-step workings but
the workaround that I've found for this
is that a few on your phone download the
Wolfram Alpha app and it does cost money
I think it was like Australian dollars
maybe like three dollars or something
okay
then it was those oh just a one-time
payment and it's on your phone and then
it always shows you the step-by-step
solutions there so I would find myself
taking my phone out like in class and
doing the logos on there so yeah and I
would say like for any stem major I
think this app is like worth it not
sponsored by them but I I definitely
think that yeah it's just a really good
way to check what you're doing even just
to see graphs as yes on the spot for so
I would go to Wolfram if I you know you
sort of understand the concept but you
don't you really can't figure out the
problem but for learning more about
concepts and for the parts of math where
I wasn't so strong and really like for
example volume integrals or surface
integrals we had to do that and I think
one of my calculus classes a really
great online resource is Paul's online
notes that's a really great resource if
you're yeah just really you don't
understand a mathematical concept it's
really well laid out and you're gonna
put the links of the things yeah at the
moment okay yeah so just check the link
in the description so another thing that
we wanted to talk about is latex and so
this is something that I guess you know
people don't really know about it until
they find themselves having to use it
it's you know for most like a way to
write documents it's could be similar to
Microsoft Word and that way but it's
different in the fact that you
essentially program it to look exactly
how you want it to look it's great
because you tell it what to do and it
does it like it's great for figures
because in word you put a figure and all
of a sudden you move one figure and
every
yeah broken and all over the place but
for latex whatever you do it stays that
way yeah it also means if there's a bit
of a learning curve before you can use
latex so if you're desperately trying to
write up a document quickly you know you
could probably just use Microsoft Word
but later we'll make it look a lot nicer
and is sort of the standard used and
science to publish like feces or
whatever it is you'll probably have to
use latex but because there is that
learning curve it makes it a little bit
harder to get started using like you
can't just you know insert fraction you
have to learn like how you type out a
fraction like backslash if are AC or
something like it so I find it can be
quite daunting to get started but it
makes the documents look way nicer and
yeah I'd recommend for anyone and stem
trying to be aware of it and start
learning a few things so that yeah it's
it's easy to make your documents look
nice yeah like you were saying in
scientific writing especially sometimes
if you're published this is like
obviously in the future but there's a
lot of journal articles that have their
own latex template and then they're like
please use our latex template and then
you can find yourself in that situation
where you're like oh I don't know so the
one thing that I would recommend you to
do if you're going to learn to use latex
is to use overleaf and overleaf there's
many different reasons why first of all
overleaf is online so usually when
you're using latex you're writing a
bachelor's thesis or a project a project
report and you don't want to be in the
situation where all of the work that
you've done is now gone because your
major died this has happened to have
more than you think yeah it really
happens more than you think because
you're like day and night slaving over
your computer you have so many classes
your computer has like catting software
on it it's like trying to work with
large spreadsheets and then the
computers just die it happens so I would
really might recommend you use an online
program
so I use overleaf additionally with
overleaf you can learn to use latex in
it because it has tons of templates so
you just go into make an account
download a template it opens up and you
can start playing with the template in
overleaf yeah I would say overly that's
probably the best thing because you can
like share documents and do
collaborations on it I personally used
to use something called text studio
which is I guess similar but it's
offline and you know you don't have the
benefit of being able to share things so
easily and save your work like on the
cloud but it's just yeah a good way to
get started and likewise just download
some templates and and try to edit them
and see what happens go from there
something else that you might not know
about until you're in a course needing
to use it is something like MATLAB or
even Python so MATLAB I guess in a way
it's a programming language but it's
also like a GUI Thank You it so I don't
know exactly what that's a program there
we go but I think it's like a matrix
laboratory is like where its name comes
from it's a way to do math essentially a
way to deal with like linear algebra and
you can you can do all sorts of things
on here draw plots process data I don't
know what you've done on it as an
engineer but um I know I've used it lots
of times just you know as a more
advanced way to solve equations and to
plot what's going on yeah so it's kind
of funny because all of a sudden I was
in a class where I needed to use MATLAB
and everyone is kind of just thrown into
this first class and our engineering you
know this was like in our second year
second semester so after we've already
done a year and a half we've never heard
of MATLAB and then you find yourself in
a class where it's completely MATLAB
they're like oh by the way all of these
assignments are done in MATLAB and we
were like what is that but the funny
thing is is that after this class almost
every single one of my engineering
classes used MATLAB for either graphing
image processing you did math yeah we
did graphing in the
processing like solving big equations or
everything I mean it's a programming
language but it's also like its own like
it has a compiler already inside of it
so you don't it's it's kind of like an
easier way to get started with
programming it's a maybe I remember when
I started using MATLAB it was for a
course it was for like a mathematical
modeling core of course and I hated it I
hated math okay I was like I don't want
to use this it's just cuz I just didn't
know how to use it and I found it was
too hard to learn like there's probably
a lot of good resources but I just said
didn't have any of those resources to
learn like and I remember thinking all
this is so stupid as soon as I get out
of this class I'm never gonna look at
MATLAB again but that's not what
happened no that was in first year and
then ever since then I've just used
MATLAB all the time and it's just become
something that I actually like using now
like yeah I just plot you just random
small things on it because it's just
actually quite easy so again there's a
bit of a bump to get over a bit of a
learning curve for it but once you get
past that point I think most people
actually know MATLAB then they use it
all the time yeah like even for you know
you can make graphs with Excel but they
will yet in that lab so that's the thing
like in my first time using MATLAB I was
like oh this is stupid I'll just use
Excel to draw these no never
now that I think that sound like wow
yeah MATLAB was so much better I would
say since we both were kind of thrown
into it and we don't really have any
resources the way I started to use
MATLAB was you download the program if
you're a student you should be able to
get it for free through your institution
and then you can find a problem that you
want to solve like if you just want to
write a HelloWorld script just Google
HelloWorld in MATLAB and some sort of
cora article will pop up and that's the
way I learned it mmm yeah so something
similar in a way to MATLAB would be
Python like that is a programming
language
and I mean in my experience I could do
similar things on both these programs so
I would use them kind of interchangeably
I found that the graphs and plotting on
MATLAB was nicer because I don't know I
I just found it easier to work with yeah
but both tools I think that a you know
forced an mages
I think Python kind of when I started to
learn it it kind of makes more sense
because everything is organized and like
functions are in libraries and all of
this stuff whereas MATLAB you have to
kind of Google the specific syntax but
other than that I would say yeah as I
said they're kind of in every
programming language it's like really
similar you just need to learn the
syntax another one it's actually similar
to programming languages is LabVIEW and
it's from what I know about it it's like
a visual way to do programming so I've
used it and only like a couple of labs
where you have to like drag and drop
various components that can control an
electronic circuit but to be honest
LabVIEW is not something I know very
much about but we had a small discussion
of yeah so I also haven't used LabVIEW
that much just in my first year
engineering labs it's a very visual way
to program and I've heard that you can
use it to program Arduino also which is
very cool I haven't done that but you
will probably encounter LabVIEW at some
point so just be aware that it's just
another programming language another
tool I think we both agree would be
useful to know something about yeah just
another tool that I've found I haven't
actually used in any of my engineering
classes but I did find myself using
excel quite a bit in one of my
internships and after you learn how to
program using excel is kind of tedious
especially if you're like why am i
acting like a cave person
and doing everything manually why can't
I just use MATLAB or whatever but the
company is using Excel so what you could
do just be aware that if you don't want
to be a cave person and you're stuck
using excel at a job you can use VBA
which is Visual Basic for applications
and it's basically the programming
language inside of Excel so everything
you do with your mouse on Excel you can
actually program Excel to do it on its
own using VBA so that's another really
cool tool and then the last one that I
thought would be worth mentioning is of
course catting software if you're in
engineering I don't know if you've got
the chance I haven't really used it but
I've seen it in action
ok I've actually looked on some of these
sites where you can get like 3d printing
just templates when I thought maybe I'd
like to 3d print something but I've no
experience really making these things on
my own in my engineering major we had to
learn how to CAD my engineering major
was mechanical engineering and even
though I don't do catting anymore
what I did find is that now I'm kind of
really valuing 3d printing and it's
really cool because I can use those
catting skills that I learned in school
and apply them to 3d printing which is
really cool because 3d printing you can
print anything you want you can build
anything you want so I find that some of
my friends that are even in
environmental science and haven't done
any engineering at all are learning to
CAD just so that they could use the 3d
printer so in school I had to learn
SolidWorks
which is a really simple program but
there's a free program online from
autodesk if you're a student I'm pretty
sure you can get all of their programs
for free so that's called AutoCAD so you
can start learning and then you can
start printing your dreams away those
sound good yeah Thank You Jess and and
that was our list of things list of
tools that might be helpful to you if
you're considering going off and
studying one of these topics so thank
you for watching and I hope you found it
useful
[Music]
[Music]